I talked to I had RSD Max on here one
time and I talked about the things that
I thought pick up because that's the
original you know manifestation of this
or one of the original manifestations of
this yeah pick up Artistry and I feel
like the three things that they got
wrong is one like logistically they were
disastrous like they never they never
explained get out of your mom's basement
they try to explain here's how to trick
a woman to coming in your mom's basement
and the other thing I think that they
completely missed the boat on with
social media and I was curious because I
you've had some of your guys on there
talking about Tinder photos and their
social media and stuff like that and not
having I loved the video you had I
forgot what the two gentlemen's name
were but they were they were on the on
the zoom call and they were talking
about the guy you know with the the
blurry photo with his dog and the the
guy remember the guy with the chainsaw
and like all these yeah all these weird
photos and I like to say like dude you
look like a child molester you look like
like you understand an attractive woman
in general thinks most men are beta and
now you're coming here with a child
molester haircut like looking like
you're going to human trafficker and
you're wondering why she doesn't swipe
right or you're wondering why she
doesn't like your ends Instagram can you
talk about how so many men have been so
uncalibrated and missed the boat when it
comes to so because you talk about
listen if I got my [__] together somehow
people have to see it you tell how
people have missed about when it comes
to dating apps and come to uh social
media yeah like the whole problem with
the pickup Artistry stuff that I never
liked is it is it teaches guys to
memorize lines
go up to girls as many times as you can
in a day
don't don't worry about the rejection if
you get one out of a hundred that give
you a number then great good job buddy
um but it doesn't teach you to lose the
belly fat to be more influential to have
a captivating life that's why most of
these Pua guys they can rack up a bunch
of notches but they don't have women in
their frame over a long-term basis it's
it's maybe like you know like a bunch of
not not just come their way and then
they just kind of go sideways they never
really do anything with themselves so
it's like you know to your point getting
out of the mom's basement you know sort
of stuff yeah that's okay well that's
kind of like a basic step like don't
live with your parents have a nice pad
have nice furniture like the Restoration
Hardware couch behind me you know what
those things cost right like you bought
like you set yourself up in such a way
that you signal to the world that you've
got yourself together and to the point
of social media and photography I mean
if you don't have a captivating
Instagram and you're a captivating guy
and you're influential and you're doing
something with your life why not like
why aren't you documenting parts of your
life
um some people say that it's
broadcasting or that it's uh you know
you you don't feel comfortable doing it
because only girls do it okay fine but
if you want women in your life if you
want to be recognized that way then
you're going to have to kind of play
that game you know it's like you know
not taking a shower before you go on a
date is optional but you'll probably be
do better if you smell good when you go
out on the date sort of thing right yeah
well I think about it I use the example
of scalability right you you think about
a guy back in the 1990s trying to pass
his mixtape out to different people out
of his truck right that's as far as he
could go until Napster that's as far as
he could go right but when you consume
this content we're doing it over off
YouTube Every any YouTube video has the
ability not necessarily the probability
but the possibility of getting a billion
views infinite numbers of people could
watch any of this content the
scalability is there so you understand
that when it comes to business why would
you not understand that when it comes to
dating and I uh another example in this
one I use you know just from the idea of
Cars one guy's got a Shelby Mustang and
the other guy's got a you know
Lamborghini and they're both leaving the
club right and let's just say for
whatever reason women recognize the
value of the lamborgh bikini 15 percent
more than the Shelby Mustang okay by the
way um Shelby the uh what's what's
Shelby's first name I forgot um Carol
Sheldon Carol Shelby went to my high
school Woodrow Wilson High School in
East Dallas
um so the when you when you have that
whole thing the guy with the lambo let's
say he has a 15 Advantage this is 1985
we're both leaving Studio 54 in New York
the guy the the valley pulls up my Lambo
I have a 15 advantage of the guy with
the Shelby Mustang now let's take that
advantage and put it on social media now
it's 15.15 to the nth power does that
make sense and what I felt like social
media did is it did not make it easier
for men to meet women it made it easier
for the top group of men to meet women
so if you had the ABS you were really
stunting on the guys who didn't and if
you had the nice car you were really
you had the vacation home in Tulum you
were really stunting on the guys who
didn't and I felt like that's that's one
of the things that people didn't
understand if a woman puts up average
social media photos and she's averagely
pretty she is going to get attention on
social media if a guy does it by
definition she thinks he's a beta but
but I just try to explain this cause I
have some you know I hang out with a ton
of Playmates because I host all these
celebrity charity events here and I'll
hang out with them and I'll go and I'll
be like hey show me your social media
let me see what the kind of messages you
get by definition every one of you who's
sliding into their DMS they assume this
is a creepy beta male who is going to
throw me into a van like that's what
they that's what they think about it you
come off as like a [__] zombie and
you unless you have a blue check mark
there you go that's exactly what they're
gonna think there you you even brought
up the blue check mark that's that's the
part that's just so crazy like and I I
understand it's not realistic from all
500 of my clients to have blue check
marks but what is realistic is for you
to show access to scarce resources for
you to wear clothes that fit to have
teeth that are straight what is
realistic is for you to have a relevant
haircut I don't know why I have so many
clients that want bushy haircuts on the
side and then it's like short on the top
I don't know where this [__] comes from
and I and I keep trying to explain to
them like you it's not that you're
coming off as attractive but
unattractive you're not even [__]
relevant you come off as like weird and
they don't they don't understand there's
like there is no level of calibration
which is one thing that I really
appreciate about your content about
Tristan's content about Justin's content
is as you guys come from a standpoint
while you're teaching this stuff you
also got look like guys who would be
attractive to women Tristan with his
suits in the cigars or whatever Justin I
mean I don't know if you ever met Justin
in public bro I walk to clubs with
Justin and all the girls that don't pay
any attention to any of us they just
stare at Justin because he's just
[__] you know division one tight end
uh and like with in your situation I
mean I can't even imagine you know you
said before you're like six two walking
around you know you're getting out of
the McLaren and be like hey how are you
doing you know it's just one of these
situations where you guys are living the
life while you're talking about it like
there's a level of calibration that goes
along with it yeah like being being
captivating is one thing but documenting
you know your your life and interesting
things that go on you know in your life
is important
um you know like I mentioned earlier I
do a lot of consults and one of the
problems that I run into with older guys
is you know they've been married for 20
years they get divorced they're in their
50s or 60s or whatever they're still in
great shape they look good they got
loads of cash they drive nice cars but
they're boring and they're not they're
not thinking along the lines of they
need to invite a chick into their life
yeah they think that they need to enter
their frame they need to you know uh
let's be partners equal Partners like
that whole you know twin tower sort of
thing and it's like no women don't want
to invite you into their life you need
to invite them into your life so when
you have a captivating social media
presence and you do interesting things
with your days or your life document it
I mean there's some people with lots of
money that have photographers that
follow follow them around you don't even
need that most people have a decent
camera on their phone just learn how to
take basic freaking pictures and
document it because what women are
thinking when they see it is like oh I
would like to be there insert myself
there on the boat or in the Supercar or
at the dinner or with these people
that's what they're looking at when they
see that right I have a buddy of mine he
he takes this photo with a drone in the
Valley of Fire he stands on this like
cliff and the Drone goes behind him and
he gets this incredible shot and he does
it for a bunch of his clients yeah and
it doesn't always have to be the
Supercar it can you can show access to
scarce resources mountain climbing you
can there's all these sorts of ways that
you can show cool places that you went
to go visit I have uh 20 IG profiles
that are my clients and I I copy and pay
whenever anyone asks a question I copy
and paste and send those I'm like get as
close to this as you can you don't need
an expensive photographer there's a way
to to replicate this and to make things
work
um one thing I want to talk about we
briefly mentioned this before and it's
the concept of men in rejection
I look at rejection as literally the
weight that the world provides for me to
lift for me to become stronger and
because of that I feel like normal men
they have to deal with rejection on an
everyday basis for some of us it beats
us down for me it's motivation if you're
LeBron James
or if you're a you know incredibly good
looking guy or if you were born
extremely rich or if you're an extremely
attractive woman I feel like there's
this dissonance between your actual
value and then what you think your value
is to the point sometimes where it's
delusional and I think that that
delusion happens because you're not
dealing with rejection all the time but
for 99 of men the world is telling us we
can't afford that car we're not good
enough to get that girl we don't have
enough money for this we don't have the
skill set the world is consistently
rejecting us and so there's two Avenues
we take this rejection and use it as
motivation or we take this rejection and
then we start saying you know [__] all
women [__] the world and then we start
talking about you know conspiracy
theories and I was just wondering like
do you use rejection as you you've
mentioned it before in your book you use
rejection as a motivation
yeah I've always used I mean I've always
said don't lose learn right so I mean
you can call that rejection but
um you know business transactions
dealing with women with friendships it
doesn't matter what it is I mean you
know you can sit there and cry like a
little [__] or you can look at the
situation and just say okay well that's
an interesting lesson that cost me I've
had lessons that have cost me hundreds
of thousands of dollars right it's like
I don't sit there and cry about it and
say oh I was rejected or that cost me
too much money or how am I ever going to
make the money back it's like okay that
was a hundred thousand dollar lesson I'm
not going to do that again and we'll go
off in this direction and I'll never let
that happen sort of thing every
successful entrepreneur every every
successful guy that I know has been
ripped off rejected hurt
um you know you name it you know they're
they're there because they because they
got back up
so it's a matter of what are you gonna
do you're gonna lay down like a little
[__] and cry or are you gonna get back
up and go and do the work dust yourself
off and then fix things right yeah
beautiful yeah definitely I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full-length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out